Joel's head does it look weird again my
day off which is funny because I'm
sitting around last time the one when I
did the spider-man video and we got
flagged and I don't know why and I can
only assume it's because the cup says
coffee is my [ __ ] hero so we're going
Empire Strikes Back for the sake of
science for the sake of testing things I
don't know why I was sitting around and
I was like I once I was itching for a
video to do that was kind of itching you
know because it's been more than a few
days since my last video and it just
makes me feel like my channels choking I
need to do something but it's got to be
something I want to do and lucky for us
like gold falling from the sky or at
least bronze there's a Jurassic world
short film battle at big rock this
sounds like a monster movie so the
premise of this is in a post Jurassic
world world in a world where dinosaurs
are now in our world one family's gonna
be like [ __ ] it we'll go camping props
to that family I wouldn't have the balls
to do that my god I mean I wouldn't go
camping in those conditions I'm the
paranoid one now I'm the one who's like
no no you put the food in the ice chest
and you put the ice chest in the trunk
because there are bears out here my god
we're not animals and we're certainly
not gonna be food today and so basically
this video being eight minutes long it's
not much to talk about stuff the fact
that this Allosaurus [ __ ] up this
camper this is Allosaurus and this
Triceratops start fighting and then the
baby in the camper starts crying and
Allosaurus is like that's pretty much
what this is this whole thing is just
like this Allosaurus wants to raid a
buffet and walks away with no food and
people in the comment section are like
oh why didn't they cover the baby's
mouth my god that's just unrealistic and
I'll be honest with you I don't know I
don't have kids all I've heard is what's
on line and I guess the the word of the
tweeters and the bloggers and the
parents who asks the question on line I
guess you're not supposed to cover a
kid's mouth because it's a little
freaked them out and you don't want to
psychologically traumatized kids
understand the parents in this
particular situation we're in a scenario
where they're like alright one of two
things is going to traumatize our kid -
that kid's gonna be traumatized
by us covering his mouth to shut him up
or the kids gonna be traumatized by
almost being eaten by a dinosaur
what's more traumatic apparently they
felt covering the kid's mouth so bring
on the dinosaur guy I could already see
Jeremy advocates for the smothering of
children not what I'm saying I just
cover the mouth obviously not the nose
and the mouth cuz you'll smother the kid
that's terrible but covering just the
mouth so you know the crying doesn't get
out at the dinosaur and the terror and
the you know everyone dying maybe but
it's all for naught because nothing was
cost except the price of a camper
because you know we're camping in this
poster assic world world where dinosaurs
are now out there and people know it
because crossbow bolts nail the
Allosaurus and the Allosaurus runs away
the girl saved the day but I'm not gonna
lie did she is that an auto crossbow I
don't know much about crossbows a lot of
my crossbow knowledge comes from
crossbows that are pre-industrial
revolution even then they're seen in
video games I don't know jack [ __ ] about
crossbows it had to have been an auto
crossbow of some sort because what's she
doing hold on loading these things no
these things hammer his head pretty
quickly just bam bam bam like Morse code
and then family gets away and I guess
this is set up for the next Jurassic
world movie or at least reminding us
that you're a secured is a thing and
it's directed by Colin Trevorrow in the
CGI it looks pretty good granted the CGI
is that night it's very dark and that's
a good way to hide shitty CGI but it
looked pretty legit to me so it's like
are we getting a jurassic world 3
trailer soon or something is this just
it can't have been just plopped down
there just for the [ __ ] of it like Colin
Trevorrow can you please direct this
short film I don't we're gonna put it on
YouTube so yeah it's 8 minutes long it's
free watch it whatever I mean not that
we haven't seen a dinosaur wreck a
trailer or a camper ever in our lives
ever it's like yeah a t-rex wrecked that
high-tech camper in lost world but now
we're gonna have an Allosaurus wreck a
family camper in this short film thing
hashtag imagination and the end credits
of this thing I actually thought was the
coolest part it's like found footage ish
movies you know dash cams and whatnot
wedding videos of people doing stuff and
dinosaurs are around you know driver
almost gets hit by a Stegosaurus tail
there's a wedding they let doves
go and pterodactyls kill the doves and
that just shows me yeah the military
would step in and kill the dinosaur
clones they'd all die it would either
happen before it got out of hand or at
the point like a pterodactyl kills a
hang-glider
fatalities would start happening but
then people would probably the all the
military Minds would get together and
they would know that dinosaurs would
start killing people and before it gets
out of hand they'd be like we need to
kill them before they start breeding and
let's just do that all right so I put a
link below to the short film let me know
what you think of it I'm spilling this
everywhere this actually keeps my hand
gestures under control to a point
because I mean too much and it said I
start splashing everywhere but let me
know what you do think of whatever you
do think comment below let me know and
as always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]